i used to imagine what it would be like
drifting towards something miraculous
something most minds could never even
comprehend
but to understand our future
we have to remember the past
and the ones who caused it all
[Music]
foundation is a thousand-year chess game
between harry selden on one side and the
genetic dynasty on the other side
the empire they're absolutely monstrous
they hold its way over ten thousand
worlds with an iron fist
threaten the peace
and pay a dear price
our world
will live on
the empire is ruled by a series of
clones and they're at different ages
brother dusk brother day and brother don
our genetic dynasty has reigned for
almost four centuries
but the beliefs of one man now threaten
the empire's existence
harry seldom he's the prophet he's the
mathematician who's invented something
called psycho history
psycho history is a combination of
psychology and history that predicts the
future behavior of large groups of
people
but
when it came to individuals
things got murkier
gail dornick she's a mathematical
prodigy and is harry selden's apprentice
she's the only other person in the
galaxy that understands psycho history
they're worried you can predict the
future
worried people believe i can
i think there's alvar hardin she's the
warden of terminus her job is to protect
harry sullivan's foundation so that the
plan will continue
all the other characters that populate
this saga they're the pawns that are
being utilized in the game between harry
selden and between the empire
the whole damn point of the foundation
is preparing for the unthinkable
foundation is fundamentally a story
about hope instrumental sacrifice we
should kill them we can murder the men
but what about the movement brother
it's epic it's epic in its storytelling
it's about how we deal with crisis it's
a very human story we will die to bring
the empire to its knees you just need to
be a fan of people who are brave enough
to go up against impossible odds and
save their family save their worlds
save the galaxy so what's the plan
you can't save yourselves
but you can save your legacy we are
empire
history bends to us
this is the plan
i'm not turning around now
you